welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spider-man no way home finally
answered one of its most cryptic
lingering mysteries what was the box
used by doctor strange to try to send
the multiverse men back to their home
realities well the film's screenplay
just confirmed its actual name la
machina de cadaves and now the film's
vfx team revealed a whole backstory was
conceived for this artifact a backstory
that explains why its destruction might
have been the final crack in the damn
for the upcoming multiverse of madness
i'm gonna explain what this box really
is and why its history was so crucial to
the madness ahead in no way home after
all five multiverse men are trapped in
the crypt strange shows up with a
machina de cadavers an ancient relic
that contains peter's corrupted spell
and he says that when he completes the
ritual it'll reverse that spell sending
them back to their home timelines where
they will die but this ritual is never
fully completed with the box the box is
kept as a fail-safe switch and a
macguffin in the second half of the film
until green goblin leaves a punking
grenade stuffed in there that destroys
the box spilling the corrupted spell
around liberty island now that boom boom
always got one of the biggest audience
whenever i watch no way home with a new
crowd and i think there's a reason we
all instinctively sensed that this box
was way way too important to be broken
now the script labels this as la machina
d cadavers cadavers comes from the
crystal of cadavers in the marvel team
up number 21 in 1974 in which spider-man
teams up with doctor strange to stop the
sorcerer's zandu from stealing the
crystal of cadavers which zandu needs
for a plot to resurrect his deceased
wife the word kadabus was also likely a
derivation of cadaver a corpse
specifically the way medical personnel
describe a body for organ harvesting and
the italian phrasing of la machina d
possibly indicates a shared history with
the italian sorcery of cagliostro writer
of the book of cagliostro in real life
alessandro de cagliostro was an 18th
century italian occultist and magician
but in marvel lore he was an ancient
sorcerer rumored to be the alias of
obeng who in marvel's what if episode 4
was the same mystic librarian strange
supreme met in the library of cagliostro
so as many of us suspected that creepy
strange variant at the end of the
doctor's stream to multiverse madness
trailer could be the same strange
supreme from what if episode 4 this is
yet another link from the live-action
side of the mcu to that particular
episode now the vfx artist from
brainstorm who designed this box adrian
sangierons sorry if i mispronounced that
in an interview with before and afters
said it used to be a much more
mechanical kind of puzzle there was a
whole backstory to it that got
simplified in the end and he cited
elaborate puzzle videos of chris ramsay
on youtube saying they wanted the box to
look like something that would take a
strong wizard to solve the initial
design was all exploded and strange is
bringing all the pieces back together he
said that they needed to figure out the
right amount of metal versus wood versus
stone to give a sense of an ancient
artifact now practically in the film one
would assume this box is at least mostly
made of wood for mj to be able to carry
it with one hand which does make sense
for ancient relics like we all saw
indiana jon's the last crusade where
indy told us a cup of a carpenter would
mostly be made of wood but i love how
this final design incorporates multiple
materials as if generation after
generation of sorcerers upgraded what
began as a simple wooden magic box with
newer and newer layers of mechanisms and
new functions that they built on this
over time an attempt to perfect it into
something better you can see how the vfx
artists went through this same process
revealing several alternate designs for
this box as they try to perfect it to
what eventually became and that final
design is directly inspired by the
design of the eye of agamotto it is also
mostly gold and green engraved with
runes and contains these inner curved
metallic bands that rotate and twist and
click aligning in a specific way to
reveal that inner peace that pops out
just like the eye of agamotto does with
the time stone now doctor strange said
that this box's function was to reverse
the spell a kind of control z based on
that function and the box's clear design
parallels with the eye of agamotto it
seems clear to me that these two
artifacts were both designed by their
sorcerers to try to do the same thing
they're both undo machines but the box
is the older model it's analog and
mechanical it requires assembly it's
clunkier it's more awkward certainly
more prone to theft but the necklace by
comparison is more portable protectable
and with the time stone far more
applicable it's almost like this box was
the gen 1 prototype and the necklace was
the final form of that they settled on
yes it is hard to know who to trust
right now especially when traditional
banks have all those drawbacks lots of
fees bad customer service no cash back
on debit purchases well albert is
completely different from any bank
account you've ever used albert is free
to sign up and easy to use you can get
five to twenty percent cash back from
places like mcdonald's or starbucks just
using your debit card just swipe and you
will see the money show up in your
account instantly albert also doesn't
charge overdraft fees ever they will let
you advance up to 250 dollars from your
next paycheck and pay it back with no
interest and no credit check managing
your personal finances can be difficult
and confusing but albert has a team of
financial experts that they call
geniuses who will look at your situation
and help you make a plan to manage your
finances and answer any questions if you
get stuck they have an easy to use app
interface and lots of great tools to
help save you money click the link in
the description box or go to albert.com
rockstars to download the albert app
today that's albert.com rockstars and
for limited time when you open a
checking account and connect a
qualifying direct deposit you will get
150 dollars and thanks again to albert
for sponsoring this video like imagine
these ancient sorcerers kagliostro and
agamoto constructing a mechanism to
house a powerful magic that specifically
would allow them to reverse mistakes so
they built the machina d cadavers which
they heralded as their 1998 imac g3
cutting edge of that era but then years
later thought uh we could do better than
a box you gotta puzzle back together
each time you want to use it i mean he's
got the time for that so they upgraded
that same mechanism to a more portable
wearable option taking all of that tech
and cramming it into a smaller sleeker
iphone form that like the iphone taps
the fuller potential of the magic to fix
these mistakes now of course the big
difference between these two artifacts
is the inner battery that fuels it the
ayabagamoto contained the time stone but
in the present mcu the time stone is
gonzo the time zone is gone atomized
making it really weird that doctor
strange is still wearing a new empty eye
of agamotto necklace presumably for
cosmetic flair but really it explains
why he's gotta go dust off this old
relic and inside this machina de
cadavers is that pentagonal prism aka a
dodecahedron that doctor strange
contained the corrupt spell inside of i
think this prism could actually be a
crystal of cadavers like the crystal
from the comics and the reason they call
this whole artifact the machina d
cadavers is the way it fixes the mistake
is by killing these foreign elements in
this universe returning them two
timelines where they become cadavers
that could be why this device would be
dooming all the multiverse men directly
to their deaths even though lizard and
sandman didn't die on screen in their
continuities why would they be doomed to
death now because the cadavers and the
term cadavers also cast this device as
really a challenge to strange his own
hippocratic oath something he has always
tried to hold himself to like when we
first met strange in his 2016 film he
argued with dr nicodemus west over
whether a brain dead patient could be
saved or as west wanted to treat that
body like a cadaver but now strange is
the one telling peter how death is their
fate and when peter begs come on strange
have a heart strange response in the
grand calculus of the multiverse their
sacrifice means infinitely more than
their lives to me this sounds like a
doctor still haunted by his choices in
infinity war and endgame choices that
are now coming home to roost as reality
melts and unravels before his eyes the
imagery matches what we saw in what if
episode 4 when strange bypassed an
absolute point to save christine palmer
and now in this universe i think
strange's choices to help the avengers
undo the snap and help peter parker
gaslight society was just too much
strain on this reality and as mordo
warned the bill has come due and now
doctor strange lives in a reality with
no infinity stones the dark stoneless
timeline that the ancient one warned
about in endgame and now he's got no
backup machina d cadavers to contain and
purge interdimensional threats i mean
potentially if multiverse madness is a
direct live-action depiction of strange
supreme and those other things from that
what if episode 4 that madness might
even include christine palmer's death
being an absolute destined point and
strange like poor zandu would have no
cadavers to use to reverse her death
he's just a scared old man with no
iphone to call 911 who dusted off his
old desktop to try to email for help but
then the local ruffians shoved a cherry
bomb in it now old man strange is old
man screwed you can support new rock
stars by checking out our merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com and big
announcement if you live in the chicago
area you'll be able to see me and philip
molina tommy bechtold and jessica
clements live february 11th 8pm at the
talia hall check out the description for
details i can't wait to meet you in
person you can follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you